the lefty
charlie barnes
making his seventh start of the season
fastball slider change up curveball
keep the ball down
control the strike zone
try to expand the strike zones get some
swinging misses
and he draws a walk amazing how he
continues to have that good eye and get
the calls
chopper to chart
plenty of time for simmons to throw
cabrera out a two-out walk is left
aboard a scoreless first for charlie
barr
an amount for the tigers
tyler alexander
he's saying call my name for next year
he's really tried to establish himself
as a starting pitcher one and two to
buxton
toward the hole and that'll leak through
for a base yet
buxton with a new bat drinking it in
with a single
two hopper to third candelario
safe at first
the force at second polanco stays out of
the double play
we got a challenge the challenge is
coming yeah from aj hinch and his staff
they see what you see gibby
yeah and he's out yeah double play good
work again if you look at esau he just
took his time make sure he caught the
ball and he's got that arm strength that
gives you that little extra zip
deep to the right field corner
about a foot foul
just to the right not of the foul pole
but the foul stripe which is in fair
territory
[Music]
third hit of the inning donaldson
driving it hard into the mound and
skipping into center field
so another long at bat
ending in a twin single
a wave and a miss and down goes to know
as he strands two
and a strikeout for out number two
there's a drive into the left field
corner that's a fair ball
squirts away from rooker
haas will cruise into second base with a
stand-up two-out double one on one
popped up near first base
it's polanco
giving way to ostidio a two out double
and hit batter are left aboard still no
score
shattered bat
get out outfield grass it'll work
and
chasing with zach short and most of the
bat ended up about
where short started his sprint
time call
nice
love it and over the back stop
and well back into the seating area i
think jack double crowd right there i
love that
i've had a guy when i was coming set to
come home called timeout and i just
threw it over the umpire's head and
everybody else is here you see foul
balls but not pitched balls into the
stands
this one flared into right center
good running catch made by akil badu
what a play i got it i got it i got it
you can see him calling it
whoo
that's why you want to break your glove
in properly see how that went right into
the pocket yeah
wow
in the air
right field grossmen today we'll
continue that discussion on the other
side we're scoreless through two
in minneapolis
taken all the way and outside a four
pitch walk
to start the third
buxton takes off
and he's in safely
oh there's nothing like seeing that live
it's incredible
one of the only guys i've ever seen that
seems to pick up speed
as he goes toward the ground most guys
start that slide and it seems like they
hit a wall slow down
one out
and that's to center
coming in as badou
tungsten will tag
and score that one's on buxton a walk a
stolen base advancing on one short fly
ball
and scoring on another
there's one in the left
and all the way into the corner up
against the wall
paredes will dig for second it's cut off
on a one out double for esau paradise
third hit of the day for the tigers
second double
and a swing and a miss good slider down
it in and
strikeouts continue for haas there's two
down
second strikeout for charlie barnes
tonight
big pop-up retreating as polanco
and it's kepler making the catch couple
more left aboard four shutout innings
three two swing and a miss and they did
it again
change up down
cenote strikes out
rooker fall tips it into the glove of
garneau back-to-back strikeouts for
tyler alexander here
and a 1-0 pitch here's the ground ball
fielded by austin deal he'll take it
himself steps on the bag
and the o2 pitch swung on a miss got him
slidered 91 that should be illegal
so three up three down for hawai'i aqua
and the twins coming to the bottom of
the fifth inning they're up one
nothing foul tipped into the glove of
garneau simmons strikes out that's the
fourth of the night
2-2 to buxton
swung on a miss
a nice clean fifth
for tyler alexander
one two three innings for the tigers
starter
there we go good piece of hitting going
to right field
a couple of hits in the inning both the
opposite way cabrera and now paredes two
men aboard for the tigers again
high fly center field
buxton back
still on the grass
getting over a scoreless six for tyler
duffy
one nothing twins bottom seven and cena
leads off
ooh
with a deep drive to left field off the
bat of suno into the second act
and the twins who haven't hit anything
hard for innings
watch to know tee off early in the
bottom of the seventh
well sometimes all you need is a new
pitcher on the mound come in changes the
feel in the dugout that's a pretty good
feeling right there
there goes gordon in the pitch
up the middle under the glove of short
gordon never went down into a slide so
he'll go to third base let's see if
kepler can break it open right now
driven to center
badou is back gordon setting up for a
tag he'll come in and score and ostadil
will hold it first jack fly kepler 3-0
game
now the 2-2
right back up the middle his second hit
of the night
back-to-back games in which eric haas
has collected multiple hit games two
outs hassan third tigers down to their
last out here's the 3-2 to aquil badou
base hit to left
drives in the tigers first run of the
night and keeps their hopes alive now
jonathan scope at the plate representing
the potential tying run now the 1-1
a bullet to center
but due is going to score
an rbi single from jonathan scope the
tigers are within one tigers down a run
it was three nothing now it's 3-2 out in
front got him
win number 70 for the twins colomey
picks up the save well a little
different way to win a ball game we saw
some runs being manufactured and then
cenote with the big home run good job by
the pitching staff a little a little
hiccup at the end but coleman still got
the save